first thing i got to bring up is
uh i'm a huge fan of elita and i know
that the chances of getting a sequel
are low but i want to know if you guys
have considered
um doing like a comic book or anything
that might talk about
what would happen after the end of the
first
film can't comment on that right now
question we'll skip on the next one got
it i read
your i completely understand
what is the secret listen my this is
going to be a huge
your movie uh uh is going to be a huge
hit for netflix
my every kid that watches it is going to
love it uh you have a knack for making
really entertaining kids films what is
the secret to making a good kids film
you know it's it's a i think it's
because i'm from a family of 10 kids
i mean that's huge so if anyone looked
at this movie to go i would not want to
direct 11 kids
in every shot like that that would be 11
people in general
but that's how i grew up so it was it
was actually easy for me and then i have
five kids of my own
creativity and keeping a childlike sense
of creativity has always been important
my life just to maintain
staying creative so it's pretty easy for
me to do i really enjoy it
i'm glad i've been able to make a
success out of because if you can make a
success out of doing something that just
comes naturally to you then you never
work a day in your life
so it's been really fun to make these
kinds of films i see the impact they've
had on kids
kids now they're in their 20s who grew
up with it tell me what it meant to them
and that's really
incredible so i want to continue that
and now with netflix i can reach more
people all over the world
on christmas and they're going to enjoy
and they can watch as many times as we
want and we'll be able to keep track
of how many times they watch it so then
we'll know that the true success of it
because you couldn't judge by kids or
you know from its budget from its
box office because kids saw it again and
again and again at home on video and
nobody knew how many times
it was a lot of times so i was really
excited to do one of these again
and use the totality of your creativity
when you make this you don't have to
limit it to just adult ideas or you know
for an action audience this is
you can use your pure imagination and
all the things you've learned from your
children and teaching your children and
playing with your kids growing up can go
in these movies
so it's it's a lot of fun did anything
change
with the powers and with the basically
with the powers of the vfx
as a result of um of of vfx
meaning like did you have a power that
you almost did but you're like that's
going to be too much or too difficult
with vfx
or it was everything your original idea
is exactly what was on the screen
you know everything got super enhanced
because when i was doing it originally
i was trying to keep my budget in mind i
had you know i wanted to be a hero over
there
netflix i said i'm going to get less
than you usually
pay for a movie i'm going to deliver
something that looks three times bigger
that way i work forever here i want to
make a bunch of these so
um but then uh i was i knew it was
limited in effect so a lot of the ideas
are really creative like rewinding time
all you do is rewind footage that you've
already shot doesn't cost anything it's
a two dollar trick
there's a lot of two dollar tricks in
the movie but for the other effects
wedda who had worked with me on elita
really loved that experience and wanted
to continue the relationship
and i said i can't afford you on this
movie and i said it's okay we'll do it
for whatever you have
so i had these bonkers effects that i
was not expecting
was not requiring and the movie just got
elevated because of what they brought to
it so i
can't thank them enough because you
watch it and you're like where did all
this come from right it doesn't look
anything like
i get movies those are the but that's
the budget i had and i got these effects
instead so
yeah i'm incredibly grateful to them so
they were able to
accomplish everything that i wanted and
then some um
so i didn't have to change any ideas
actually i got to just enhance things
along the way if anything i am sure that
as i said earlier this is going to be a
huge hit for netflix
um the thing about kids is they grow
very fast so
where are you in the development of a
sequel
well um if this movie does well i've
already got ideas in mind
because we have to jump right into it
but we don't we're not
we don't have firm plans to do anything
yet but they're definitely looking to
see how
how this does i think it's going to do
well but until it really does come out
you can't really
bet on that but um i'm hoping it does
well so everybody
see it on christmas day
do you see yourself uh helming a sequel
do you see it um
do you see it like that helmet yeah i
love making these and i shoot very fast
and you have to have somebody that
really knows what they're doing because
having that many kids
you've only gotten for six hours you've
got to shoot them in six hours that's
half a day
you got to really know what you're doing
so that's why i operate the camera
that's why i'm dp that's why i'm the
editor
i used to be the composer too but then
my son kicked me out of that job he did
better than i did
he took over i lost that job now so
but uh it's uh you've got to just be on
it and um
and you can't you can't phone those
things in you've got to be there 100
to make them work because it's uh it's
tricky you know it's tricky to make
that many kids work in a in a movie and
then we'll probably just be adding
characters in the sequel so yeah i
really love them enough to that i'd want
to help
was it always going to be this title did
you have something else in mind it was
always that title and i came up with it
actually in the room
when scott stuber said we'd like a
family series from you of some kind you
know like movie
like you did with spy kids and i thought
no one's i can't believe
all the superhero things they've done
movies tv shows spin-offs side
characters
no one's done one with kids so that's
for sure
and i had just been listening to that
song and i thought we can be heroes is a
great title because
it's saying that we can be curious too
now finally when it's just been nothing
but adults
but also adults would have recognized
the reference and think that that's cool
so it kind of worked on multiple levels
i have to switch subjects because i
thought you did a great job on
mandalorian
which i think which just played a few
days ago what i'm curious about is
did you have a lot of deleted scenes
when you shot that because
there is no set run time that they have
to release
so like how does it work in the editing
room um
no i mean the script was really short
the script was much shorter than the
episode the script was like 19 pages
so that suggests 19 minutes so i added a
lot of action to just
in fact i even asked john is that um is
that okay then my script's only 19 pages
is okay they're because i cut really
fast and it's probably going to end up
being
16 minutes right because do we need to
add more pages and you go no that's what
you're here for you need to fill that up
though okay i'll try and make that
battle longer so that's where a lot of
that
extra battle came from was just trying
to not because i knew my tendency was to
cut things pretty tight so i thought
if i have 100 page script it's a
90-minute movie so i had a 19-page
script i thought wow i'm going to run
out i'm going to run out of things
so i added a lot of action um what did
it mean to you because you got to be the
one who introduces the slave one
to the series um what did it mean to be
bringing back boba fett and slave one
um because obviously you must have grown
up with all this oh but
this was like 12 year old dream you know
um
like when i was 12 is when empire
strikes back came out and i was a huge
boba fett fan
because you know it was they would tease
them out before the movie came out
you already knew he was going to be a
character to watch before
the marketing was really great like this
character boba fett
and so when you saw the movie you
couldn't wait to see him um
so he captured your imagination before
the movie came out it's all we were
talking about at school i still remember
that
how mysterious that character was and
you got a little taste of him
but you were waiting to see more so yeah
when i saw the script
john sent me the script and it said you
know boba fett
and dark troopers and mando and fennick
and i was just like this doesn't even
feel like a real script it feels like a
fan wrote this in a fever dream hoping
that this would be an episode
and yet this was the script it had all
the good stuff in it i it was like a
greatest hits of all the cool
i couldn't believe i got that gift to go
play in star wars with all the
the toys and get to play with boba fett
as one of your main ones
i just thought i i got to go in there
and just have him be
i don't know if he's going to show up in
any more episodes or what so i got to
just make him super badass
in this moment be that character that i
imagined it being when i first heard
about him when i was 12.
that was my mission just to go satisfy
that 12 year old
uh fascination with the character
on that note i gotta go congrats on
everything uh wish you nothing but the
best
appreciate it thank you